- We will halve inflation this year
to ease the cost of living
and give people financial security.
- [Narrator] That was UK
Prime Minister Rishi Sunak
at the beginning of the year
pledging to cut inflation in half,
which at that time was 10.5%.
Inflation has since fallen
to 8.7%, which is good,
but experts and officials
are more interested in
something else, core inflation,
which has actually risen
since the start of the year.
What's behind that rise?
And what does it mean
for Rishi Sunak's big pledge?
(audience applauding)
First, it's important to
understand the difference
between core inflation
and headline inflation.
- Headline inflation is
the classic benchmark
for consumer prices.
It calculates an index
based on stuff that we buy,
like food, energy, rent, clothes,
and a whole bunch of other stuff.
Core inflation strips out
the more volatile things
like food and energy,
and this is the metric
that the Bank of England
is closely watching right now.
- [Narrator] UK headline
inflation is falling,
but at a slower pace than
of a major economies.
It's still twice as high as in the US.
The UK's core inflation, meanwhile,
is traveling in the opposite direction.
It's now at its highest level since 1992,
fueled by higher wages
and corporate profits.
- One of the big drivers
of this is services,
so that's prices for
things like air travel,
cultural goods, other kinds of services.
This is in contrast with
the US and the Eurozone
where core inflation has
been coming down recently.
In the US, one of the big reasons for this
was the cooling of housing rental prices.
- [Narrator] Persistently
high core inflation
could make the Prime Minister's
goal harder to achieve.
The Treasury Chief says, "The
target of around 5% inflation
is still possible, but it won't be easy."
- I think the sweet
spot for the UK economy
in terms of our long-term competitiveness
is if we can do the best of
what European countries do
in terms of investment in skills,
investment in infrastructure,
but have that US
dynamism, innovation, spark
- [Narrator] Hunt's desired sweet spot
will in part depend on if
that core inflation rate
can start to follow the US and Eurozone
in a downward direction.
The government is supported in its efforts
by the Bank of England.
The Central Bank sees
raising interest rates
as its best tool to bring inflation down
to its own 2% target.
It has been raising the
rate since the end of 2021.
This makes borrowing more expensive,
which leads to people
having less money to spend,
which lowers demand on goods,
and ultimately, slows prices.
- Central Banks have had a
really difficult job recently,
they've been trying to tame inflation
with interest rates being their main tool,
but they also have to try
to raise interest rates
without damaging the economy too severely.
So it's about finding this
delicate balancing act.
In the US, we've seen the
Fed pause interest rates
while it's assessing the
impact of his latest hikes,
but it does look like in the UK
because of this
persistently high inflation,
the BOE is unlikely
to be able to pause its
hiking cycle anytime soon.
(tranquil music)